senhoras e senhores a conversar com
vocês sobre inovação e à primeira
questão que eu faço
acontece no ted ex se o palestrante
saída bola vermelha tem uma bola
vermelha aqui que vocês talvez não vejam
palco é mais alta
fiquem pensando nisso que eu vou
retornar mas eu queria começar mesmo com
a excelente notícia para todos os
educadores
senhoras e senhores a aula valeu calma a
aula como um instrumento de sustentação
de pedagogias baseada num monólogo e
metáforas antigas e tradicionais de
transmissão do conhecimento e retenção
da aprendizagem mas porque essa é uma
boa notícia porque isso nos deixa livres
para repensar a engenharia didática da
escola dos sistemas de ensino e em
particular em uma arquitetura inovadora
de transformação dos ambientes de
aprendizagem na escola e pra mim essa
arquitetura tem quatro camadas que
gostaria de contar sobre as quais
conversar com vocês hoje e trazer
exemplos da minha própria prática
profissional em ambientes diversos essas
quatro camadas são os cenários de
aprendizagem os espaços físicos que a
gente transforme em lugares de
acolhimento da dos processos de
aprendizagem
as experiências que nós oferecemos aos
nossos alunos aprendizes e professores
em situações diversas como é que a gente
monta relações entre as pessoas que
estão nesses ambientes
e como é que inovação é de alguma forma
sustentada por redes ecossistemas que
tornam esses processos escaláveis o que
eu vou fazer daqui pra frente é trazer
alguns exemplos dessas quatro camadas
com ela se articulam como a gente é uso
isso então para transformar os sistemas
de educação os sistemas de ensino e as
bolas vermelhas que nos prendem dentro
das escolas
o primeiro é a questão dos cenários a
veja os mundos são é nóis psicólogos
dizemos player ou matizadas eles são
ricos em elementos artefatos
instrumentos de representação ricos em
significados que permitem com que as
pessoas realizem em conjunto de
atividades e mercy vaz muito intensas
a educação infantil é muito boa de de
demonstrar isso para crianças e
professores geralmente a participação
autoral das crianças e dos seus
professores principalmente professores
da educação infantil é revela esse mundo
prega um batizado
mas ao longo da escolarização isso vai
sumindo então as paredes por exemplo das
escolas deixam de ser na educação
fundamental e no ensino médio em
particular no superior deixarão de ser
esses displays da atividade das pessoas
mas isso não precisa ser assim e embora
por exemplo cartaxo não seja inovação
nenhuma 5ª série por exemplo 5º ano
eles podem ser nem curso universitário e
de psicologia cultural semiótica uma
coisa totalmente abstrata é eles podem
ser aqueles elementos que permitem que
alunos universitários jovens adultos
possam expressar criativamente é
conhecimento sobre uma coisa tão
abstrata e usar as paredes da
instituição não apenas como elementos de
controle mas como displays materiais ou
vitrines de conversação esses cartazes
que a gente usa uma disciplina na
universidade de novo embora não seja
novidade porque essas pessoas já
passaram pelo quinto ano mas a retomada
disso e principalmente a reconquista das
paredes da universidade são uma dessas
inovações muito simples que eu reputo
algo como encapsula em inovação coisas
que a gente pode começar a fazer
segunda-feira mas não precisa ser tão
simples a gente pode complexo ficar um
pouquinho no sesa por exemplo
a numa actividade de residência que
fizemos o sesi é o centro de estudos e
sistemas avançados do recife em uma
residência que fizemos para jovens
programadores nós pedimos que eles
imprimissem o código que estavam
realizando e colassem nas paredes porque
isso virava um instrumento de diálogo
então isso é como a aula pode ser
desfeita através de um conjunto de novas
engenharias didáticas essas muito
simples que podem ser realizadas de
forma encapsulada daqui a pouco segunda
feira a segunda camada de inovação nessa
arquitetura são as experiências e como é
que a gente nesses mundos agora
ornamentados a gente coloca a
experiência em primeiro lugar e as
formas significativas não só para os
alunos mas para os professores também
naquela mesma disciplina de psicologia
cultural sem óbvio que eu comentei ainda
pouco a gente faz com que os grupos de
alunos observem a atividades sociais
diversas como pegar um ônibus e consigam
reconhecer nessas atividades
os conceitos altamente abstratos de
fronteira simbólica amar matilha
semiótica coisas absolutamente abstratas
mas que por porque são sobre a cultura e
são a sobre a atividade humana
naturalmente você consegue ver luz na
parada de ônibus por exemplo então a
atividade é e ao mundo e capturar no
mundo aqueles conceitos que em uma aula
baseada em monólogo apenas seria é
tão-somente definições e não é isso que
a gente quer a gente quer de fato
superar a aula como esse instrumento de
construção de significados
através de experiências que possam fazer
esses alunos a ascender ao concreto
fazer do concreto a matéria mesmo do
pensamento mas não precisa ser coisas
tão simples podem ser coisas muito
sofisticadas como a gente tem feito na
jóia street numa empresa do porto
digital da qual sou sócio fundador
quando a gente desenvolveu todo
olimpíada de videogames
que é tem matzá as competências e
habilidades do enem ou da prova brasil
inserindo-a nesses jogos diversão e
diálogo em experiências que mudam
completamente o arranjo social da escola
vocês vêem na foto o tipo de engajamento
que raramente você consegue numa aula
são times de jovens crianças aliados aos
seus professores para resolver desafios
que fazem evoluir as competências
desejadas pela escola
então eu tenho há agora não mais
conteúdos mas um olhar sobre
competências inseridas em narrativas
então a escola deixa de ser uma lista de
coisas a serem feitas para acerto para
ser uma atividade experience ao e
imersiva e altamente ofensivo isso fez
com que a gente repensa se o próprio bpn
escola pra construir algo que a gente
chama o t3 dna uma brincadeira com essa
idéia de você
a ré em itá a própria escola é esse de
trainee até o primeiro grande diversão
então usando mecânicas clássicas de
videogames e processos de educação para
engajamento diálogo porque todo o
processo de aprendizagem ele é
essencialmente dialógico uma estrutura
de desafios com um feedback constante
que faça com que as pessoas realmente
saibam o que estão fazendo ou seja eles
de senso de propósito como todo o
videogame é capaz de realizar inserido
numa narrativa tornando portanto a
aprendizagem é uma aventura e não apenas
um dever
então esse é o debreceni aqui a gente
tem construído lembrando essa é a
segunda camada das quatro cenários
experiências mas isso a gente só
consegue fazer se a gente construir
relações entre as pessoas
e aí é a idéia desse da construção
dessas relações
e obviamente todos já notaram que eu
tenho usado filmes de sessão da tarde
basicamente para ilustrar
algumas dessas coisas há lá mesmo em
ghajar você em algo lúdico que é - á a
bola vermelha do trf e é mais uma
atividade engajada como o cinema então
como é que a gente constrói a partir de
uma perspectiva de inovação e
empreendedorismo essa relação entre as
pessoas na mesma universidade federal
a gente tem uma disciplina inter de
empatar departamental envolvendo ciência
da computação engenharia de software
design psicologia onde os alunos
aprendem a estudar problemas da
sociedade
desenhar soluções para esses problemas e
desenvolver ao longo de um semestre
soluções físicos digitais que envolvem
eu toda uma arquitetura de pesquisa e de
ação e produção ao longo de um único
semestre essa disciplina conhecida como
projetam então a gente está engajado as
pessoas montando para elas um conjunto
de relações que reformular toda aquela
arquitetura os três eixos tradicionais
da universidade ensino pesquisa e
extensão fazendo da universidade agora
um lugar de educação com ênfase na
construção de cenários de aprendizagem a
missão da escola não é ensinar é a
construção desses cenários de
aprendizagem com a ênfase não é mais
ensino e sim em educação pesquisa mas
com foco na visão do futuro e inovação é
faltado a servir à sociedade através da
construção de práticas de empreendendo
empreendedorismo mas o empreendedorismo
que podem empreender por exemplo a sala
de aula pense mas ao pensar na sala de
aula ela própria como espécie de startup
o professor como empreendedor dos alunos
seus colaboradores pra desenvolver
coisas experiências e atingir metas
conjuntamente então essa ideia a de um
autor italiano chamado o foguete mas que
é f foca na reformulação de toda uma
engenharia didática da escola academia
que é
a gente precisa é ultimamente realizar
isso tudo chega na concepção de redes
lugares cenários lugares enquanto
cenários experiências significativas
construção de relacionamento entre
pessoas através de atividades que
constroem redes ou ecossistemas de
mudanças
esse é o caso por exemplo do porto
digital hoje mais de 320 empresas mais
de 8 mil colaboradores um faturamento
bastante acentuado que deve chegar a 2
bilhões de reais este ano que é um
ecossistema produtivo que traz a
universidade para junto dos governos
para junto de problemas de mercados de
capital empreendedor
então a idéia da construção de
ecossistemas é da escala aquelas
experiências significativas feitas na
própria universidade
agora a idéia de redes é também promover
dentro da própria escola de ensino
básico por exemplo uma formação
inovadora de professores capaz de tornar
o professor de maneira hiperlocal um
autor de suas próprias práticas não
replica a dor de práticas didáticas
baseadas naquela aula falida sobre a
qual conversamos no início
então essa é um outro um outro é é
cenário de aprendizagem para a formação
que nós construímos junto com algumas
pessoas de são paulo chamado lev
laboratório de experimentações de
táticas onde a gente meio que replica a
idéia do startup weekend
mas só para educadores e não pra
construir aplicativos mais uma
reengenharia didática da escola com
práticas inovadoras para a sala de aula
a idéia de construir essas redes na
escola de ensino básico por exemplo ou
na academia é também você poder
reformular a centralidade do que a
educação fala se muito na educação
centrada no aluno e isso tem um certo
sentido
agora mas tem um passo adicional que a
gente pode é se aventura a dar juntos
que é construir uma rede de
relacionamentos dentro da escola onde a
educação passa a ser centrada na
construção de vínculos professor aluno
então isso é é trabalho é uma questão
muito importante da escola que é o
desengajamento na verdade o abandono
afetivo e intelectual que crianças
jovens e professores vivenciam dentro da
escola de ensino básico e para a qual a
gente tem que dar conta
então é mudar o seu olhar é para uma
construção de vínculos professor aluno é
uma dessas inovações que conectam novos
cenários de aprendizagem com
experiências significativas que são
autor adas localmente dentro da própria
escola então é isso é muito importante
principalmente agora onde a gente tem
uma base nacional reformulada que se não
é perfeita é pode ser um instrumento de
trazer transformação e inovação para
dentro de uma reflexão acentuada sobre
como agente rearquitetar para a sala de
aula com pessoas e à formação de redes e
ecossistemas que traduzem aquelas
pequenas inovações em cartaz no aparelho
que a gente faz de forma encapsulado a
partir da semana que vem para os
professores da sala vizinha
os professores de toda a escola as
escolas de toda a rede então a inovação
ela tem essa característica principal de
engajar em ecossistemas um conjunto de
atores sem os quais a inovação morre
cenários experiências pessoas e redes
agora o que acontece se o palestrante
sai da bola vermelha e se vote if porque
não há inovação
é uma prática de risco as escolas
obviamente são uma prática de manutenção
também e permanência histórica inclusive
se é absolutamente necessário porque
lidamos com pessoas que estão em
desenvolvimento em evolução mas a
inovação não vai acontecer se a gente
também não tomar o risco de sair dessa
zona que lhe foi designada
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]